[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
make some noise for hip-hop history
[Applause]
he's back there getting stumped
[Applause]
it was a
it was a trans man
[Applause]
yeah a little bit
[Applause]
[Music]
you know i spent two years in prison so
i see the danger
yeah that means you [ __ ] get caught
in your [ __ ]
you got cut damn bro that guy's been
[ __ ] in every hole you've never seen
exactly i'm way more cheap than you bro
i'm way more gangster than you
you snitched hey you snitched that's how
you got out of your bed bro i took that
[ __ ] down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i'll tell you if you guys don't
shut the [ __ ] up about 200 people are
going to beat the living [ __ ] out of you
all right
[Music]
cause we got people can just take you
out here so fast and it'll be like you
have a parking lot going huh
[Music]
i know it's okay state
i've seen your license plate oklahoma's
okay it's like you know why not being a
model man but by god it's okay
i don't know if you're in oklahoma
that'll get oklahoma
i guess if you were gay you'd be in
oklahoma
but you know
no really don't mess with me because i
don't come down to the bus station and
slap the dick out of your mouth when
you're working do it
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
i'm sorry man the guy [ __ ] came at me
what do you think folks
okay sure
that was unnecessary
like the washington monument i'm like
somebody got paid to design that [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] pencil
i mean that's it it's just a big [ __ ]
cement pencil some people think it looks
like a dick but i think they're saving
that design for trump's monument uh i am
no [ __ ] you stupid all right
[Applause]
what are you his [ __ ] mom get the
[ __ ] out of here oh god i am i the first
one to dislike trump oh my god i must
have invented disliking donald trump hey
on your way out remember you can suck my
balls any time you won all right
[ __ ] break up my show lady you know
what you come up here and do this [ __ ]
and and yeah oh yeah go [ __ ]
[Applause]
i heard she was a [ __ ] but
and right now like i still got to do
comedy you know i mean like
like you ever go to a family reunion and
your uncle cusses out your grandma you
know and
somebody comes up like who wants cake
you know like i i gotta
i gotta be the guy who goes who wants
cake right now i mean
dude [ __ ] what
what the [ __ ] was that
did she get mad at anybody else for
talking [ __ ] on trump you know who's got
the hardest job tonight
javier beldem and his wife are both
nominated
now if she loses he can't win
[Laughter]
he is praying that will smith wins like
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out your [ __ ] mouth i'm
going to okay
so i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
you know folks sometimes comics have to
go on the road and perform for monkeys
right moose jaw 2001
and a joke
i don't think you've watched the show so
far
this is no choose your own adventure
story
if you can turn to page 85 it turns out
i [ __ ] your mother
[Applause]
and you don't want to know what you're
whispering in my ear
oh
his mother's dead
that guy better get the [ __ ] out of here
right now or i will call the police
because that's assault
i didn't ask him to be a [ __ ] monkey
he yelled [ __ ] up that's not how the
show works
like i knew his mother passed away
[Music]
now folks legally i don't have to
continue this show
i can't stop i'm actually in pain right
now that did not [ __ ] feel like a
feather okay
but i'll do a few more minutes
because i don't like [ __ ] like that okay
he [ __ ] brought it on himself i don't
care if you like me or hate me
so here excuse me i'll talk to you this
way
i just wanted to get out
annoyed me so much
it's because you try to tell people what
to do
don't tell people where to look that's
not how you communicate with adults you
don't tell them look in my eyes
not your dog and i'm not a [ __ ]
little kid
no you don't talk to people like that
that's dumb that's not going to pull my
cigarette up his nose but that's like
god
so don't threaten it i'm not thrilled
this is dumb [ __ ] no it's actually this
is fine no it's dumb
she talks enough [ __ ] to you a puncher
because i'm not going to punch him
either
you're going to then that's [ __ ]
that's dumb no you say no i'm not saying
you're talking to me you're saying
you're going to burn me with your
cigarette not burning anybody that's
dopey talk
[Laughter]
i'm in very good shape
[Applause]
i'm gonna burn you and then you touch my
face